- [Voiceover] Let's say
that I have two numbers
on a number line.
So let me draw a little quick number line
right over here.
The two numbers on my number line
that I care about, the
number a and the number
represented by b here.
The way I've drawn it, b is to the right
of a on our number line,
and by our convention, b is going
to be greater than a.
So if I were to figure out the distance
between a and b, what
is this distance going
from a, I want to draw
a straight line here,
this distance going from a to b,
so this distance right over there,
how would I figure it out?
Well I could just take the larger
of these two numbers,
which is going to be b,
and then subtract out the smaller.
So I subtract out a, and I'll be left
with this distance.
This will give me a positive value.
When I want a distance, I just think
in terms of a positive value.
How far apart are these two things?
But I was only able to
know to do b minus a
because I knew that b was greater than a.
This was going to give
me a positive value.
What if I knew that a was greater than b?
Well then I would do it
the other way around.
So let me draw that again.
Let me draw another number
line right over here.
In this world, in this world,
I'm going to make a greater than b.
This is b, that is a,
and if I wanted to calculate the distance
between b and a here,
well now I would take
the larger of the two,
a, remember I want the
positive distance here,
and then I would subtract out the smaller.
I would do a minus b.
Well so here I did b minus a,
here I did a minus b,
but what if I didn't know
which one was greater?
If I didn't know whether
b or a was greater,
what could I do?
Well what you could do is just take
either a minus b or b minus a
and take the absolute value.
If you do that, it doesn't matter
if you take b minus a or a minus b.
It turns out that regardless of whether a
is greater than b, or b is greater than a,
or they're equivalent,
that the absolute value
of a minus b is equivalent
to the absolute value
of b minus a, and this is equivalent,
either of these
expressions is the distance
between these numbers.
I encourage you to play
around with the negatives
to see if you can factor
out some negatives
and think about the absolute value.
It will actually make a lot
of sense why this is true.
In another video, I might
do a little bit more
of a rigorous justification for it.
But I think the important thing
for this video is to see that this
is actually true.
So let's say we're in a world,
let's get a number line out,
and let's look at some examples.
So let's say that we want to figure out
the distance between,
between, let's say negative two,
the distance between negative two
and positive three.
So we can look at the number line
and figure out what that distance is.
To go from negative two to positive three,
or the distance between them,
we see is one, two, three, four, five.
Actually, let me draw
a straighter line here.
This distance right over here,
this distance right over here
is equal to five.
You see it right over here.
One, two, three, four, five.
Or you'd have to go five backwards
to go from three to negative two.
But let's see that what I just wrote
actually applies right over here.
So if we took negative two to be our a
and three to be our b,
then we could write this as
the absolute value of negative two
minus three,
what is this going to be equal to?
Well this is going to be equal
to negative two minus
three is negative five,
so it's the absolute
value of negative five.
So this indeed equals five.
So notice I subtracted the larger number
from the smaller number.
I got a negative value, but then I took
the absolute value of it.
That gave me the actual distance
between these two numbers.
Now what if I did it the other way around?
What if I took three minus negative two?
So it's going to be the absolute value
of three, let me do it in the blue color,
the absolute value of three minus,
and in parentheses I'll
write the negative two.
Negative two.
Now if you subtract a smaller number
from a larger number, you should get
a positive value.
So the absolute value sign
here is just kind of extra.
You don't really need it,
unless to verify that that's true.
This is going to be
three minus negative two.
That's the same thing as three plus
positive two, or five.
So this is just going
to be the absolute value
of five, which of
course, is equal to five.
So hopefully this makes you feel good
that if you want the distance
between two numbers, you subtract one
from the other, and it doesn't matter
which order you do it.
You could subtract
three from negative two,
or negative two from three,
be careful with the negative symbols here,
and then take the absolute value,
and then that is going to give you
the distance between these two numbers.
This is super important because later
in your mathematical careers,
you're going to see a math professor
just say, oh, you know,
I care about the distance
between two variables, you know,
a and b, so the distance is a minus b,
and then later they
might write it like this.
And then to realize that these
are actually the same thing,
and these are gonna give the same value,
and they represent the distance
between these numbers.